JD I don't use the word hillbilly you
know I'm talking about country people
and that sort of thing and I've always
felt kind of shy about using it and you
used it proudly tell me what is a
hillbilly yeah well so as my grandma
said hillbilly is something that we can
use in the family but if somebody else
calls you a hillbilly then you have to
punch him in the nose and the idea is
that it's an insider's term of
endearment and the way that we used it
in our family is one that you had some
connection to the land of Appalachia or
Appalachia depending on where you're
from how you say it that you really love
that land you love the people who live
there and I do think there's just sort
of country element to it it's not just
about Appalachia itself it's sort of
about loving the rural lifestyle and
having some connection to it either
familial or otherwise you've had the
book out for a while you've had all
sorts of people do exactly what I did
tell you about how oh yeah they came
from a similar kind of family and the
rest of it to what extent do you still
see the hillbilly culture in which you
grew up to be distinct from other white
working-class environments that people
have talked to you about yeah so that's
that's a very interesting question I
think the answer is that it's still
somewhat distinct and a lot of what we
think of as white working-class culture
I still think that we what we're really
talking about sometimes the sort of
scots-irish or Appalachian rooted
culture though obviously there's been so
much assimilation that it is sometimes
hard to figure out where one stops and
the other begins but you know there
there's this interesting argument that
you know we ought to just call it the
United States of Appalachia because a
lot of what we think of is sort of
classically American values are really
rooted in Appalachia in different ways
there's a really good book book to that
effect but you know III think that it's
it's important to sort of recognize and
one thing I've tried to do is recognize
that a lot of these issues agree in the
broader white working-class but I do
still think that there's a lot of
connection to Appalachia well you know
the in the census responses the group of
people that responds to the question of
what's your ethnicity background your
ethnic background the ones who say I'm
American are the Scots that's exactly
right that which in my case I've always
bragged about my scots-irish
ground and I have said well we were
violent and we were drunk but we made
great pioneers I didn't know the half of
it until I read your book in terms of
all kinds of stuff that that that goes
on in in the culture you describe
question to what extent your child of
the 90s right that's right basically
were growing up then as you listen to
your parents and your grandparents to
what extent has the hillbilly culture
evolved since 1960 yeah well I think
it's it's definitely evolved almost
because it's been forced to evolve right
so one of the things my grandparents I
think realized after they moved to
southern Ohio is that a lot of the
values that they brought with them
didn't necessarily translate into sort
of middle-class American life and that's
an understatement
but I I think because of that you know
especially among sort of upwardly mobile
folks who have some connections to
scots-irish or Appalachia there's
definitely an impulse to sort of discard
your hillbilly this there's a
recognition that it's maybe something to
be ashamed of or maybe just something
that you don't want to highlight I think
it's been really interesting actually
since the publication of the book to
watch my cousins who both grew up in
very sort of middle-class families
they're both in college one is 21 one is
19 and the way that the book has sort of
brought them back in contact with their
roots because they did I mean they knew
my grandma very well and they didn't
realize how much she was a sort of
cultural figure and how much they you
know they really are part of that
culture even though they don't
necessarily see it as something that's
that's broader than themselves are these
relatives of yours who are the children
of the one was it Milwaukee he went to
or no so ankle Jimmy is in Texas he went
from he went from Middletown to Texas to
California back to Texas
these are children of an Thuy who's sort
of a very important character in the
book and to what extent were they aware
of the heritage of that they had they
did whether you said they didn't know
your grandmother was the way she was
what note they certainly knew the way
that she was and I don't know that they
quite placed it in a broader or regional
and cultural context and so one of the
really and
seeing things that my my cousin did she
wrote this really beautiful piece about
my grandma and about sort of recognizing
where she came from
in the wake of the book coming out but
she even said she sort of tried to hide
her hillbilly nests she started she
didn't tell other people about these
outrageous family stories and I didn't
either until I got older I started to
appreciate that they were maybe
something you know unique and
interesting and not something to be just
ashamed of but it was only after I
graduated from high schools you know as
I said in the book a lot of my very good
friends heard about these stories for
the first time while reading them in the
book it's not something I really bragged
about until I got older
you